my guest tonight is a comedian and an
actress who has appeared in curb your
enthusiasm blackish and pooty tang
greatest movie title of all time now you
can see her
in the new film breaking news in yuba
county
please welcome one of my favorites wanda
sykes how are you wanda
i'm doing quite well how are you conan
i'm okay
i think i speak for all of us when i say
hold up with family
uh during quarantine it can be great
and then there's a whole other side of
that coin how are you doing
i you know what um i'm afraid to
complain
yeah that's how i am you know it's like
oh no i'm good
yeah good yeah you see the rest of
the stuff that's going on i'm like you
know what i'm pretty good
but um yeah it it's
i know exactly what you mean about being
held up with family and
yeah doing the online studies you know
school
it's yeah well who's like for example
who does the cooking in this situation
in in your house who does the cooking
well i like to cook
i like to cook um so i i do most of the
cooking
um but it's been uh you know like i said
not gonna complain but i haven't had an
oven
since uh like two weeks before
thanksgiving
did your oven blow up or something what
happened just die
i don't know what happened you know
usually when i go away for a while
and i come back something's broken
something's not working
right anymore right this time they they
killed the oven
so i think uh it's hard to get you know
what it's i'm thinking about it
it's hard to kill an oven it really is
hey i
i don't know how she did it but uh alex
broke a volvo
you know how hard it is
[Laughter]
alex is your wife she broke a volvo yeah
i'm not
i shouldn't say she did it well all i
know is my car was fine
and then she drove it i came back
it was it was in the shop for like two
weeks
[Laughter]
wait so you don't have an oven how do
you cook if you don't have an oven you
said you haven't had an oven in months
what do you do
everything is has been going on the
grill anything that needs to go on the
in the oven i cook it on the grill which
is real fun when it's you standing in
snow
yeah that's right because you're you're
on the east coast now so
man uh uh grilling out in the snow
is not it's not a joy no and i i know
my neighbors are probably like man you
know i i knew black people like barbecue
but
she is taking it
[Laughter]
this is not helping with the stereotype
that's the problem yeah
now wait a minute are you doing uh
shopping yourself
or you do instacart like a lot of people
like to get on the phone and do that
instacart
uh during uh a pandemic or do you like
to go yourself
i like to go myself but i'm not you know
i don't go like
uh often i make a quick list i do a huge
you know shop and i do the face mask and
the face shield
and all but uh you know i was i was in
uh whole foods you know um
spending my kids college fun and um
trust me it's incred you go to whole
foods and you look at the like
a bag of grapes and you think i need to
call my accountant first
it's incredible yeah so yeah but anyway
so you're at whole foods
right and i'm doing my shopping and at
first you know i
i guess not really paying attention but
i'm like wow
that's like got a lot of young black
people in here
shopping at whole foods we coming up
this is nice and i realized like oh no
they're shopping for other people
like oh they're the instacart shoppers
right they're doing
yeah they're actually going to shopping
and then i was like
damn dad you know all these young people
putting them putting themselves at risk
doing the shopping and they gotta go
home to their parents or
other family members who you know like i
said it's like
really putting us at risk but
hey white people enjoy your chilean sea
bass
[Laughter]
yeah that's uh that's not right that's
not right yeah
uh well what about your kids
or your kids i'm thinking nope i have
not eaten chilean sea bass for a while
so i have no guilt there
uh are your kids i mean they're doing
the learning online because
mine liked it at first and then they
started to burn out on it
are they doing are your kids okay with
school online
um they are and they actually get to go
to school so it's like
you know back and forth oh that's good
that makes a big difference
yeah it breaks it up yeah we like them
going to school
yes yes my son likes online
yeah i'm about to enroll my son in the
army
just to get him out of the house you
know he doesn't know about it
and he's only 15 but i'm going to talk
to the government and see if i can just
let's get him stationed in guam for a
while you know hey if you give me a
twofer
[Laughter]
you know i'm curious about something we
you talked about you mentioned your wife
alex uh alex is french right
is are your kids growing up learning to
speak french are they learning it
so that they can be fluent learning they
are
they are they are fluent they are fluent
right they are
fluent in french that's that was their
their first language
that's their first language that is so i
think that's very cool myself i think
to have that kind of to have a brain
that's that knows two languages
and is learning them that early is
incredible but
is it weird if alex and the kids are
speaking french
and you're there at the table does that
get awkward
um it does it does and you know i'll
ask hey can we you know because the rule
is at the table
especially you know but we speak english
um
but you know they slip into the french
but here's the thing
i i know a little bit more french than
i'm letting them on you know letting
them know you know they're not on to me
yet so i i
listen and you know i can pick up stuff
and i freak them out too because if
if uh i hear them talking about the food
and if my wife says something like oh
this could use some you know mustard
and i'm i'm sitting there and i'll eat
and i'll go
you know what i i think this could use
some mustard and they're all like
oh they freak out like
[Laughter]
that's great they think you have an
amazing palette or that your extra
sensory perception
um you and i have a similar had a
similar experience that i wanted to
bring up which is both of us
uh hosted uh the white house
correspondents dinner
during the uh o'brien i'm done deal
brian
that's an amazing freudian slip
during the o'brien administration
yes announce something conan i i just
want to say that i feel in many ways i
co-ran the country with barack obama
during that eight-year period
no during the obama administration we
both
had a chance to do the white house
correspondents dinner uh that's a
thrilling gig
i found it to be very exciting i had
done it once under clinton
and then uh with with the with the
obamas there
what people don't know and i think you
had this experience too
is that uh the comedian goes after the
president
so we're sitting there and president
obama would get up
absolutely destroy great jokes amazing
delivery
and i was sitting next to you you sit
next to the first lady so you sit next
to michelle obama
while you're watching the president kill
and then you know you have to go up next
what was that experience like for you uh
you pretty much mapped it out yeah i
mean it's
you you're sitting there and you you
have your you know i can't i have my
cards
and he's just killing and he's doing
some
stuff that i was going to do so yes
that's what
that's what i wanted to talk about yeah
yeah yeah
so i'm you so you really have to listen
to make sure you don't you know
do a joke he's doing right and um
and while he's doing or he's going
through you know doing his act
the first lady is just like trying to
talk to me trying to make
you know make some some some contact
here and
and i know she was just being nice being
very generous and trying to make me feel
comfortable and
maybe trying to relax me but that's not
what you do to a comedian
when we gotta go up who's about to go on
yeah
no i know exactly what you're talking
about because i was sitting there
and i'm i'm watching uh the president
like a hawk
because he's doing he's covering all
these all these areas
and of course i've got my like 50 cards
of all the jokes i'm going to do
and i'm flipping through and then he'll
mention something he'll he'll he'll
mention an area and i'll go like ah
and i'll find that card and rip it up
and meanwhile yes yes
mrs yes mrs first lady yes mrs obama yes
the
i i do like pudding i'm going to have my
pudding hold on a second what's that huh
and it's just it's crazy making it's
crazy making
but it was still you know uh she was
absolutely delightful
and incredibly nice
and then um one of the first things the
president did when i was
uh sitting there when he got up was he
made some kind of just fun harmless dig
at me like it was a roast and he just
did a dig at me and the whole
crowd was wondering what do we think
about this and the first lady shook her
head like
no and gave me a put her arms around me
like not conan
and the whole crowd was like
they booed the president
so i oh i owe the first lady a huge one
uh for that um let's talk about
uh breaking news in yuba county uh this
is a really fun roll for you
i can tell you're having fun with this
roll uh
first of all you get to wear this
incredible wig this amazing wig
my career would be so different if i had
this wig
that's stuck with this it's fantastic
um and and you get to play this
character who really let's let's let's
to just i don't know let it all hang out
there like there's a scene where you
destroy
stuff in a mall you absolutely just you
you destroy a bunch of things
and looking at you i can tell wand is
having fun
oh my god it was the best it was a
jewelry store
and we were you know pulling off a heist
so smashed through the
through the mall through the glass and
everything ripped the
door off of the jewelry store with our
uh tow truck right
and just go in and just start smashing
stuff smashing and grabbing it was the
best
you know the the prop guy had to run a
couple times to tell me no no not that
case
they finished that case you got carried
away a little bit yeah that carried away
a little bit but i mean
it was i mean i never felt that before i
mean you know
just to run in destroy stuff and and
with with not being held responsible or
no repercussions i'm like it's like a
little taste of what it's like to be
white
well and then you go home and you order
chilean sea bass
you don't even leave the house well we
have
uh a clip here and this is really fun
this is a fun scene where
um you're holding aquafina
prisoner and uh you've got a gun on her
and i've never been in a movie as an
actor but i've always thought
it must be fun i'm not a gun person i
don't own a gun
but it must be fun as a kid you know i
ran around with a cap gun it must be fun
to have a gun in a scene you know when
you know that no one's gonna get hurt
and it it feels like
this is this is you having more fun in
with this character
oh yes all right let's take a look at
this uh
this clip from breaking news in yuba
county
now we don't want to hurt you well
you're gonna die tonight you're gonna
die tonight you're gonna die nobody's
dying tonight just just
hey yeah yeah yeah it's gonna call the
boss make an even exchange
so everybody just chill out yeah yeah
chill out oh oh i'll cheer you well
you're not gonna do [ __ ] old lady holy
[ __ ]
here you still [ __ ] here oh [ __ ] take
this talk to him i'll keep her quiet
nina so we will kill her oh
i'm gonna rip your door it's gonna be
your face
god damn it i got to go janelle i got to
go
janelle's in labor would you mind if i
held on to this yes i do mine you know
what you are right this belongs to you
this is yours this year
you don't shoot her whole air off just
her earlobe just her earlobe
just your little cause because i'm not
really that good at it
and i didn't even want to shoot her at
the it kind of just went off
yeah yeah that's right so it's it's okay
too if you're gonna lose a part of your
body just earlobe i think
kind of acceptable you know um
you're saying yes exactly you did her
which
is a favor in my opinion she should have
paid you
um did your parents i know that your
parents
i believe got vaccinated mine got
vaccinated last week
and yours got vaccinated as well yes my
mom is actually
i talked to her today she's getting her
second shot uh if not tomorrow
and the following day yeah right so
she's
i'm very excited about it she's happy
about it
and uh my dad he gets his next shot i
think the following week whatever so
uh you know anything that can get her
back in the casinos
she'll she is she's going to be happy
she likes to give her the church
that says her her two things are she
likes to go to the casino
and she likes church she can find a
church
with some slot machines
[Laughter]
i hope that for her you know um it's
also important to get the message out i
know that in the african-american
community
there is rightly some suspicion
about the vaccine when i say rightly i
mean historically
there's a good reason why uh black
people
uh are wary of a government-endorsed
vaccine
but we want to get the word out that i i
think
uh of all the people that have been
vaccinated so far
i think sixty percent are white and only
five percent
are are black and we want to make sure
that people
in in that community know that these
vaccines are safe
and they need to go out when it's their
turn and get a vac get vaccinated
absolutely my parents are in their 80s
the first
uh shot they had no problems with and
they're
you know very excited to get the to get
the second one yeah um
yeah it's safe and i mean we are
it's killing us it's our communities are
uh being the most affected by it so we
yeah
got to get this vaccine okay i'm i'm
glad i'm i'm glad you're getting that
word out there and i'm glad your folks
are doing well
uh let me make sure i get the word out
on breaking news in yuba county
uh it's terrific it's now available on
digital
and in select theaters and
you want to see this film just to see if
nothing else
wanda's really funny great performance
and this wig
i'm telling you this week is fantastic
wanda thank you so much for talking to
me and uh
continue to stay safe and uh don't take
any [ __ ]
off these people you know talking french
to you in your own home
you know i got you conan i got you i got
your back all right thank you wanda
appreciate